SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So before we begin, I would
like to just ask
a very simple question.
Do you think randomized
evaluation are the best way to
conduct an impact evaluation?
Please raise your hand
if you think so.
Just be honest.
All right, the TAs, you
guys don't count.
All right.
OK.
So I have a job to do now.
Whereas I thought
that maybe not.
One of the things I would
like to do is to--
this is one thing I've
discovered about teaching.
We have about an hour
and 25 minutes.
And if I speak for an hour and
25 minutes, I know two things
will happen.
One, you will get very
bored, and two, you
will not learn anything.
So I want you to make sure
that you interrupt with
questions that you have.
If they can be on the topic,
that would be very good.
If they're are off-topic, I may
delay the question or I
may postpone the question, at
least until I get there.
The other thing I would like
to say about the way this
would work, is I have
no power over you.
Whereas my students, I have
a grade to give, with
you I have no power.
But I will still ask you to do
certain things during the
presentation.
So I hope you'll collaborate.
So my session is called
Why Randomize?
And the idea of Why Randomize?
comes, for those of you who are
convinced, I hope you can
use this session to help
convince others why this
method is a very good method
to do an impact evaluation.
And for those of you who are not
convinced, I would like to
actually welcome you to raise
any objections you have.
And I'm not here to tell you
randomization is a panacea or
it's a solution to all the
problems of mankind.
But I think in terms of impact
evaluations, it's a very
powerful method.
So the outline of the talk, I'll
give you a little bit of
background.
We'll define, what is a
randomized evaluation?
It's going to be important
to make sure we
have a common language.
Then advantages and
disadvantages of experiments.
Then we're going to do the get
out the vote, and then finally
conclude in hopefully an
hour and 20 minutes.
So how to measure impact?
This is something that
Rachel referred to.
The idea for measuring impact
is, we want to compare what
happened to the beneficiaries of
a program versus what would
have happened in the absence
of the program.
This is really key.
What would have happened in the
absence of a program is
what's called a counterfactual,
and it's key
for you to evaluate any method
to estimate program impact.
Not just randomized
evaluation.
So when you are trying to assess
how someone is going to
do an impact evaluation,
always ask yourself the
question, what is the
counterfactual here?
How are they planning to think
about this counterfactual?
How do these people look like in
the absence of the program?
In the case of Kenya in the
textbooks that Rachel was
referring to this morning,
we thought about the
counterfactual in terms of how
these children fared after
this textbook program was
implemented versus how they
would have fared at the same
moment in time had the program
not been implemented.
This is crucial, because even
before and after methodologies
or any other of those
methodologies, you are
assuming implicitly
counterfactual.
And the question is, what
counterfactual are you
assuming, and then is that
assumption realistic?
And in some cases, it may be.
In other cases, it may not.
So the problem is, the
counterfactual is not
observable.
So the key goal of this
impact evaluation
methodology is to mimic it.
You can't observe how this
children in Kenya would have
fared if the textbook program
had not been implemented.
The truth is, the textbook
program was implemented, these
textbooks were sent, and so you
can't observe what that
alternative reality
would have been.
And so constructing the
counterfactual is usually done
by selecting a group
of people--
in this case, children, in the
case of the Kenya example--
that have not been exposed to
the program, or were not
affected by the program.
And so in a randomized
evaluation, the key goal here
of the randomized evaluation
is that you
do it from the beginning.
And this is a question that I
think Logan had in the first
session with Rachel.
You can't do a randomized
evaluation three years after
the program was implemented.
And the reason you can't do it
is that you need to create,
through this randomized
experiment, the treatment in
the control group.
You need to decide early on
who's going to get the
treatment or who's going to be
offered the treatment and who
is not going to be offered
the treatment.
There are some opportunities,
as Rachel referred to, and
your get out the vote case is a
good example, where someone
already did this.
And so you may be lucky, and you
may step into the room and
say, oh, look.
Someone did it.
But this thing is, someone
should have taken care so that
the assignment to this treatment
and control group
was done in a random manner.
And in effect, and we'll see
what exactly is random, but
what I can tell you for now is
if someone doesn't say, we did
it randomized, we did a
deliberate process so that it
was random, it's probably
not random.
Random is not what people
say in the real world.
Oh!
This is just a random event.
Random has a very specific
definition which we're going
to see in a second.
So it's not enough to
just say, oh, look.
We didn't do anything
systematic.
Just people enrolled, and
that's what happened.
If they didn't do something
deliberate to do it random,
then it probably
wasn't random.
You can try to check this,
but not always possible.
The non-randomized, basically,
I use that some excluded
group, the group of people
you're going to use as this
comparison group, it's mimicking
this counterfactual.
And the non-randomized methods
rely on the strength of the
assumption that you're making.
So the methods will be strong
if the assumption that the
comparison group mimics the
counterfactual is a good
assumption.
There's not any sense in which
you say, well, this method is
better than other this other
in some absolute manner.
It is better or it's not better
if the assumptions
needed to mimic the
counterfactual hold.
If they hold, then that's great,
you have a good method.
The key distinction
between this--
yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you give us
an example of when the
assumptions were just
obviously untrue?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So suppose that you had this
textbook program and it was
happening in Kenya,
where many--
and this is program happened--
where many other things
were happening in
this education system.
So textbooks were being
distributed, different
teachers were being hired.
A lot of activities
were happening.
And so you just compare what
test scores of children were
before the program and then
what textbooks of children
were after the program, you
would suspect that--
well, first of all, if you did
that, the counterfactual you
would be assuming is that in
the absence of the program,
test scores would have
remained flat.
And that may be a reasonable
counterfactual in some contexts.
Not many, to be honest.
But not in others.
So in one context in which other
things happening in the
education system in Kenya, it's
very hard to argue that
nothing would have changed
in test scores.
Because test scores would have
increased, because there are
lots of things that happen.
Now suppose you implemented this
same program in a very
remote village, very secluded
area where nothing else would
have happened.
You sort of have a pretty
good sense that no other
intervention was happening
for one group or the
other at the same time.
The assumption maybe
more plausible.
I think in this case, the
textbook example, it's still
questionable, because there are
other educational input
said may be happening.
But the key is that the context
and the method are the
ones that together can
tell you how good
the assumption is.
The method by itself
cannot tell you.
The method by itself may be
reasonable under certain
conditions but not
under others.
AUDIENCE: But there aren't any
sort of big famous studies
that weren't randomized, that
everybody thinks they're
pretty good?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So I don't want to get a lot
into this, but there's a whole
debate now in economics
literature as to whether
randomized experiments
are the only way to
estimate causal effects.
This is a big, big debate, and
there are very respectable
people on both sides
of the debate.
What I can tell you is that
debate has not been solved,
but I think more and more
people are sort of
recognizing, at least, that
the randomized experiment
should be a first best.
I think even the opponents of
the method do say that.
But the other thing I would say
is there have been many
studies trying to compare the
results of an experiment with
some of the other
non-experimental methods.
You have one in your
get out the vote.
That was not a study in which
the non-experimental methods
fared very well, but there are
other studies in which they
fared well.
The key thing is we haven't been
able to figure out under
what conditions the
non-randomized evaluations
fared well.
If we knew, then it
would be nice.
But I think so far,
the answer--
we don't know.
We know the theoretical answer,
which is, if the
assumptions hold,
we're golden.
The problem, key problem, is
that this is relying on the
assumptions, and you cannot
test these assumptions.
If you could test this
assumption, if you could test
under what assumption this
mimics the counterfactuals,
we'll be all done.
We'll be able to say, from the
very beginning, we can use
this method.
You cannot, no matter how
sophisticated and how good the
non-experimental method is.
Yes?
You seem skeptical.
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
PROFESSOR: You're--?
OK.
So this is very confusing.
It's like twice they're
showing--
you should do a randomized
evaluation
to see if this helps.
Two boards.
All right.
So the randomized evaluations
here, you have a bunch of
other names in which they are
known-- random assignment
studies, randomized field
trials, just in case--
RCTs are the way that they were
known very early in the
literature, and still nowadays
in other disciplines.
And then the non-experimental
methods, all of this that you
have here, some of which
are in your get
out the vote study.
All right.
So before we go into what is a
randomized experiment, I want
to introduce the notion
of validity.
And Rachel raised
it a little bit.
But we usually think of in terms
of two kinds of validity
when you assess a study.
The first one is internal
validity.
This has to do with
your ability
to draw causal inference.
So your ability to attribute
your impact
estimates to the program.
So if you said, this difference
is my impact
estimate, the study has strong
internal validity if you can
reliably attribute that to the
program and not to something
else for whatever population is
represented in your study.
So if you did the textbook
project in Kenya, in a rural
village in Kenya, well,
that study--
if it's internally valid, or
if it has strong internal
validity, then it's going to
be valid for the population
represented by the sample you
drew in Kenya, in that rural
village in Kenya.
External validity, on the other
hand, has to do with the
ability to generalize to other
populations, other settings,
other time periods.
The reason I mention this is
that these two things often
trade off against each other
when you are sort of trying to
commission or conduct a study.
So you may decide, I'm going to
go this randomized trial in
this very small place to
test out my model.
And you may be concerned with,
how do I know if it
generalizes to other settings?
On the other hand, you may
decide, well, I'm going to use
other kinds of methods and be
representative of the whole
Kenya, or the whole India, or
whatever country you're
working in.
The key thing is to distinguish
two things.
The first one has to do with
causal inference for your own
sample, or for the population
represented in your sample.
The second one has to do
with generalizability.
And Rachel talked a little bit
about how much you can
generalize from experiments,
and we can talk
about that if you want.
All right.
So what is a randomized
evaluation?
So the very basics--
can someone tell me what
the basics are?
Randomized experiments?
How do you do it?
How does it work?
There's one thing that
you should know.
When I first started teaching,
I used to be very, very
nervous when there was
silence in the room.
But now I'm very comfortable.
So you tell me.
So how does a randomized
trial work?
AUDIENCE: Allocate the subject
into the treatment of the
control group based on
a random assignment.
PROFESSOR: OK.
random assignment.
Sort of like a flip
of a coin, right?
So in the simple scenario, we
take a sample of program
applicants--
just like we do with
drug trials--
take a sample of program
applicants and we randomly
assign them either to a
treatment group which is
offered the treatment
and a control group.
They're not offered
the treatment.
This is a very simple setting,
but the idea here is that by
doing this, the treatment and
the control group are
comparable to each other.
And so any differences you
observe between these two
groups should be attributable
to the program.
The key about this method--
so this do not differ
systematically at the outset
of the experiment.
The key about this method is
that this control group is
mimicking the counterfactuals.
It's mimicking what will happen
to the treatment in the
absence of the treatment.
And the reason it's mimicking
the counterfactual is that on
average, this group should
be exactly like
the treatment group.
So if we took all of you and
we flip coins, from each of
you we flip coins, and then you
ended up in two different
groups, the two groups would
have, on average, the same
characteristics.
So the same people
that come from a
certain area of the world.
The same percent of females.
The same average intelligence.
The same average income.
The same average education.
You name it.
We're going to do an exercise
where you can see this.
The beauty of this method
is that the two groups
statistically are going to be
identical to each other.
If they're not identical to each
other statistically then
you don't have random
assignment.
It has failed.
Random assignment.
So the random assignment is
the process you employ to
create these two comparable
groups.
The huge advantage of this
random assignment is that you
don't need to think about, are
the two groups the same on
this characteristic
that I care about?
You don't need to think
about that.
The two groups should be the
same on those characteristics.
AUDIENCE: So that's
theoretically.
So now thinking in terms of a
program where you have, say,
selection criteria.
So let's say you want to do
a program in a particular
district, and you're looking
for people that have three
characteristics that
are all the same.
Let's say for whatever reason,
the number of people that
present themselves in that way
is a relatively small number.
Then you can randomly select
within that small number.
But then you're challenged by
the size of your group.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
And on Thursday, you'll
get to that
minimum sample size detected.
But the key there, if those
three characteristics are your
selection criteria, you don't
want to modify your selection
criteria because someone is
going to come and do an
experiment.
You want to offer the program
to whoever you're going to
offer the program.
So those three characteristics
are key for your program,
because you decide those are the
people you want to serve,
then you need to find a way
to do your evaluation that
doesn't involve relaxing
that criteria.
Unless you really are thinking,
well, it would be
interesting to know if I served
this other group,
whether the program has a
different effect or no.
AUDIENCE: But you can't mix and
match among the criteria.
You can't say-- or could you?
Let's say you have trouble.
You're not getting
enough people
with those three criteria.
So you say, OK, now we're going
to make it six criteria,
and we'll be happy if they only
meet four of the six.
That right there would not make
it possible to do this.
PROFESSOR: So if, at the end
of your processes, where
you're saying three criteria,
six criteria, five, four,
whatever you say-- if at the end
of this process, you end
up with a large enough pool to
be able to randomly assign
into two groups, treatment
and control?
No problem.
You could have relaxed
the criteria.
You could have said six, five,
four, whatever you want.
My previous answer is more to,
don't change the criteria just
because you want to do
a randomized trial.
You want to evaluate
the program
that you want to evaluate.
You don't want to evaluate the
program that you think will
fit the randomized design.
Make sense?
Other questions, comments?
No?
OK.
So the two groups did not differ
systematically at the
outset of the experiment.
I want to emphasize this.
And again, there's going to be
an exercise where you can see
this in Excel.
But the key is that the two
groups will be identical both
on observable characteristics
and non-observable.
And when I say identical,
they're identical
statistically.
It's not like the needs
of these two groups
are exactly the same.
They are statistically identical
in the sense that
you should not observe a pattern
of statistically
significant differences between
the two groups.
If you were to test 100
characteristics, then five of
them may end up being
statistically significant,
just because of the luck of the
draw or multiple testing.
But they shouldn't differ
systematically at the outset
of the experiment.
And this is the key.
The whole key of impact
evaluation is that then you
can take that difference and
attribute it to the program.
And then you're not thinking,
is it the program, or is it
some pre-existing differences
between the groups?
If you reach the end of an
impact evaluation and you're
wondering, is it the program,
or is it something else?
Unfortunately, that's not a very
good impact evaluation.
So there are some variations
on the basics.
You could assign to multiple
treatment groups.
So rather than having only one
treatment, you could have
multiple treatments.
And this happens a lot if
you're trying to test
different ways of implementing
a program.
So you may have a program that
you're thinking, well, I don't
know of the best way to deliver
it is method number
one or method number two.
And you may randomize
into three groups.
Method number one, method
number two,
and a control group.
Or you may decide to do away
with the control group and
only randomize into, say, three
methods, three ways of
delivering an intervention.
If you do away with the control
group, you're going to
be able to answer the question,
is one treatment
better than the other?
But you're not going to be able
to answer the question,
is any of this treatment better
than what would have
happened in the absence
of the program?
So this is one variation.
And the other variation, we were
talking about when Iqbal
answered the question.
He said, well, you have
a bunch of people.
You assign some to
the treatment or
to the control group.
You can assign units other then
people or households.
Health centers, schools, local
government, villages.
And you can see in
JPAL's website.
There are a bunch of examples
where each of these have been
used as units for random
assignment?
Yes?
Your name, please?
We don't have name tags,
but I like to call
people by their name.
Wendy?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So if we pick schools,
my conclusions will
be about schools.
They won't be about the students
in the school.
Or is that wrong?
PROFESSOR: So it depends on--
you say your conclusions will
be about the schools?
The key thing is, what is the
unit of intervention here?
So it's a program that's
directed at all the children
in the school, only some
children in the school?
In part, the decision of what
you randomize, whether it's
schools or children within
schools, depends on what's the
nature of the treatment.
So if you have a program
that serves everyone
in the school, yes.
Your assignment should be
at the school level.
That is, you should have some
schools that receive the
program and others that don't.
But if you have a program that
is only going to serve some
children in the school, then
your assignment could be
within the school, and you have
some children who receive
the treatment, and others
that do not.
The key, though, is if you're
using your second method, you
want to make sure there
are no spillovers.
You want to make sure that
someone receiving the
treatment is not going to affect
the outcomes of someone
not receiving the treatment.
And so you're going to
see the spillovers.
That's something you're going
to see on Friday.
But the basic idea is, what
level of randomization you
have depends on, what is the
level of your treatment?
If you're treating schools, if
you're treating individuals
within schools, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: So statistically I
want them to be the same.
PROFESSOR: You want them
to be the same, yes.
AUDIENCE: My name is Manuel.
Please talk a little bit
about the unobserved
characteristics.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So the unobserved
characteristics--
this is something that a lot
of the non-experimental
methods wrestle with.
And the idea is, the randomized
experiment creates
these two groups that, by pure
laws of statistics, are
identical in every single
characteristic,
statistically speaking.
So both the ones you
observe and the
ones you don't observe.
So if we were trying to do an
experiment in this classroom
and I randomly assigned you
into two groups, I can be
confident that even things I
don't observe about you,
you're going to be balanced
across those two groups.
If instead I try to match you,
I use all the information you
gave me on your application
forms and say OK, these people
are from this--
I'm going to be able to do so
with the observables, but not
with the unobservables.
And again, depending on how
important these unobservable
are in explaining the outcomes,
that may be a big
disadvantage or not so
big disadvantage.
And this is what happened in the
get out the vote example.
You were able to observe some
characteristics of people.
And then non-experimental
methods, all of them--
I mean, not all of them,
but most of them--
can address those.
Some of the methods can also
address some unobservables,
but again, they always rely on
some assumption about how
those unobservables behave.
Here you're not relying
on any assumptions.
You need to do the random
assignment properly, but once
it's done properly, you're not
relying on any assumption.
AUDIENCE: Is that the
general dichotomy?
There's randomized tests, and
then matched pairs tests?
Or is there other , is
it generally broken
down into those two?
PROFESSOR: So the way that I
think most people break it
down is randomized, where you
use this random assignment,
and then non-experimental
methods.
But I don't mean to imply that
all the non-experimental
methods are the same.
And in fact, there are some
people who called them
quasi-experimental methods.
Those people tend to think of
them a little bit higher than
the non-experimental methods.
Non-experimental people tend
to say, this is not good.
Quasi-experimental, oh, this
gets closer to the experiment.
But the key thing here is that
whatever method you use, the
key is how are the people
getting into the program being
selected, and how are you
forming that comparison group,
and what statistical techniques
are you using to
adjust for whether that
comparison group is the same
or not than the treatment?
So the dichotomy is not between
randomized and matching.
The dichotomy is usually
between randomized and
everything else.
But within everything else,
there are methods that are
much better than others.
Yes?
[? Holgo? ?]
AUDIENCE: How do we randomize
when we assign people into
treatment and control groups,
besides a lottery?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You mean
the process?
So tomorrow, the whole
day is going to be
about how to randomize.
But the basic idea is, you can
do it in a variety of ways.
You can do it in a computer,
which allows you a lot more
flexibility.
But if for any reason, you
need to show people that
you're doing it in a random,
transparent manner, that can
also be done.
We just did one in Niger in
West Africa where we used
bingo balls.
So literally, people would
draw from there, and then
everyone could see.
If we had brought a computer
into their room in Niger and
tried to do things, it just
wouldn't have worked.
People would have said, what
are you doing here?
So there are there of many
different ways of randomizing.
The key-- and this is something
we're going to talk
about in a little bit--
is what exactly is the process
that you use to make sure that
it's random assignment, not
the how, you know, whether
it's bingo balls or a lottery
or a coin or whatever it is.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So at what point this
week will we talk about
the ethical dimensions of
denying treatment to someone?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Like in three slides,
you can jump at me
with the ethical issues.
And then if I don't satisfy you,
you have four more days
to jump at every single people
who comes into this room.
So what I want to give you
is a little bit of
the nuts and bolts.
Rather they keep this discussion
in the abstract,
this is what happens
in the experiment.
The nuts and bolts, if you
wanted to do a randomized
experiment tomorrow, these are
sort of eight key steps that
you need to think about.
This is a very simplified
description of the process.
As those people sitting in the
back will tell you, this is
very simplified.
Their daily lives are consumed
with many of the steps, and
they work months, if not
years, in each of this.
The first step, and I can't
emphasize this enough, is to
design the study carefully.
So no matter what you do, what
you do at the beginning is
going to affect you study for
the rest of the study.
This is true for some things
in life and not others.
For evaluations, impact
evaluations, if you don't do
it right at the beginning,
you're going to be in trouble.
That's going to come
down to haunt you.
So anything you can do to spend
time at the beginning,
making sure that the study is
designed properly, is going to
be very helpful.
What that means, in very
practical terms, is if you are
in a position where you are
commissioning a study, and you
don't have people in your staff
who are expert at this,
make sure that whoever is
going to help you do the
evaluation is involved from
the very beginning.
What this also means is that
calling someone three years
after the program was
implemented, saying, can you
come and evaluate?
That leaves the evaluator
with very few options.
So the earlier the evaluators
are involved, the better the
options are in terms of
how you can do this.
Both in terms of the validity of
the evaluation, but also in
terms of how it will interact
with the program in a way that
it doesn't disrupt
the program.
So this is key.
And we can talk about design a
little bit now, but you will
learn a little bit about design
when you speak about
sample size, about measurement
issues, and all of those
sessions are coming.
How to randomize.
So Wednesday and Thursday
are really about that.
The second one is to randomly
assign people to treatment or
control or more groups, if there
are more than those.
The third one is to collect
baseline data.
So this is a big question
that comes up.
Should you collect
baseline data?
I think my answer to that is, in
general, if you don't have
a randomized evaluation, it's
going to be very, very, very
difficult to get away without
baseline data.
There are some methods
that work, but
it's going to be difficult.
By baseline, I mean, before
the intervention started.
If you have a randomized trial
it would be highly preferable
to have baseline data.
Highly preferable.
But not as critical as
with other methods.
And it's preferable
in two ways.
The first one is if you have a
baseline data, you can verify,
at least in terms of those
characteristics you collected
in the baseline survey,
you can verify that
two groups look like.
This is a nice thing to verify
at the beginning and not at
the end of the evaluation.
So if you can do it, that
would be helpful.
And the second thing you
have to do is-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
What happens if, at the baseline
data, you realize
that the two groups that you
made were not random?
Do you go and keep randomizing
until you get there?
PROFESSOR: So it depends.
It depends on when you
discovered this.
If you discover this when the
treatment is already being
implemented, it is too late to
do anything else in terms of
re-randomizing.
The ideal scenario is one in
which you can do this, collect
the baseline data, randomize,
verify that they are similar,
and then if they are not
similar, then you can
re-randomize again.
There's controversy about how
many times you should do this,
but for the most part, in
general, if you randomize, the
two groups should
look similar.
There are very few scenarios,
but they exist, where they
don't look similar
to each other.
And if you reach one of those
scenarios, you can
re-randomize.
What you can't do is
re-randomize when the
treatment is already
being distributed.
So if you already decided,
you're in the treatment group,
you're in the control
group, you can't
re-randomize at that phase.
The second reason you want to
collect data, and this is
going to be important
particularly in a setting like
yours, if you are worried about
sample size, is that it
buys a lot of statistical
power.
Particularly if you can collect
data on the baseline
version of the outcomes
that you care about.
If you can do that, it's
highly desirable.
The reality is that sometimes
it's feasible to collect
baseline data and sometimes the
nature of implementation
of the program makes
it difficult.
But you will do well if you
can collect baseline data.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't it seem
that by the very fact of
collecting the baseline data,
once we have already
randomized, can bias this
randomized by collecting the
baseline data?
PROFESSOR: Because you're
affecting the people who are
answering the survey?
Well, this has to do a little
bit more with survey design
than with any other thing.
The key is, you're going to
collect baseline data for both
the participant or
the treatment
and the control group.
So if you feel that when
people answer a
survey, they somehow--
I don't know--
get optimistic about life and
do better or the other way
around, as long as it happens
in the same way for both
treatment and control groups,
it's not a problem for the
randomized trials.
The problem would be if, for
some reason, you think that
administering a survey is going
to affect the treatment
and the control group
differently.
If that's the case, then you
need to be careful about how
you do the survey.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain how
[INAUDIBLE] statistical power?
PROFESSOR: So in technical
terms, what happens is, you,
in your regression, where you
estimate an impact, you have
an outcome of interest.
And that outcome has a variance,
has some variations.
And then if you can add into
your regressions statistical
controls, things you collected
at baseline, what essentially
happens is, in technical terms,
the standard errors of
your coefficients, particularly
if these
variables have a lot of
explanatory power, those
standard errors should
drop, and you get
more statistical power.
Yes, Jessica?
AUDIENCE: Do you mean to say
that you have to collect the
baseline data after you do the
first round of randomization?
Does it matter what order
you do those steps in?
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
Steps two and three
can be inverted.
In fact, it would be ideal
if you could invert them.
It would be ideal, because
then you can do
what Iqbal is saying.
Which is, you collect the
baseline data, you do the
randomization, and
then you say, OK.
Are they the same or not?
Then if they're not the same,
you re-randomize.
If you collect the baseline data
after randomly assigning,
unless you have not communicated
to people who
gets the treatment and who gets
the control, your options
for re-randomizing are
not very good.
So very good point.
All right.
So the fourth step is to verify
that the assignment
looks random.
By verifying that the assignment
looks random, this
is something that if you were
to commission an evaluation,
you should make sure
that your evaluator
provides to you this.
Which is at the very least a
table that says, here's the
treatment group, here's the
control group, and here's how
they look like in terms
of these baseline
characteristics.
And ideally those two groups,
those tables should have very,
very few differences
between the groups.
When I say differences, they
cannot be, in practical terms,
large differences.
There could be some differences
that are
statistically significant,
because either you have a lot
of statistical power, or more
likely, if you compare 10
variables, some of them will
end up being significant.
The key is, there are no
systematic differences between
the groups.
If you observe systematic
differences,
then you're in trouble.
This didn't work well.
But I can tell you from
experience, from the law of
statistics, these two groups
will look the same
a lot of the time.
OK.
So obviously you can only do
that verification if you have
some data on the two
groups before.
Now, when I say "collect
baseline data," if maybe you
already have baseline data--
for some reason this is a
population that you're ready
serving, you already did
surveys on these people--
if that's the case, then
all the better.
It may be that you don't have
baseline data, but you may be
able to get baseline data.
So for example, if you're
randomly assigning schools,
you may have, from the
government or from some
agency, some census
of schools.
And you may be able to compare
schools in terms of
socioeconomic characteristics
of the students.
You may be able to compare
schools, you know, percent of
private, public.
If there was a test done
nationally for all the
schools, you may be able
to compare test
scores on those schools.
The key thing is, anything you
can do to verify that, will a
random assignment work?
Is good.
It would be useful to do
it at the beginning.
The fifth step is to monitor
the process so that the
integrity of the experiment
is not compromised.
This is something that's
really, really key.
When you do a randomized
experiment, designing the
study carefully is
very important.
Doing the random assignment
is very important.
But you can't just relax and
then wait for two years until
you collect the outcomes.
And the people who are sitting
at the back of the room know
this much better than I do.
If you are not following exactly
what's happening in
the field, the opportunities for
this experiment to not go
well are very, very big.
You're going to have a whole
session on Friday on threats
to an experiment.
The only thing I will say now
is that the best way to deal
with threats to an experiment is
to avoid those threats, and
to avoid them at this stage
of implementation.
One very quick threat.
If you assign people to a
treatment group and people to
a control group, that means
that people in the control
group are not offered
the treatment.
But that also means, they
shouldn't get the treatment.
And as some of you know, that
doesn't always happen.
So some people in the control
group find their
way into the program.
Having systems to monitor that
this doesn't happen, and that
if it does happen, that it
happens in very, very few
exceptional cases, is going
to be very important.
Yes, Logan?
AUDIENCE: One of the arguments
for the superiority of the
matched pairs is that if one
treatment group ends up not
getting the treatment because
lack of capacity in that
region, or vice versa, the
scenario you described, you
can just drop that pair.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The problem when you drop
that pair is that it may
be costly to you.
Dropping that pair.
And you have to assume that
that-- well, first of all, you
have to assume that pair was
comparable to begin with.
And then even if you were to
drop that pair, well, first of
all, matching doesn't always
work on one-to-one.
But even if you had one-to-one
matching, suppose you had to
drop 10% or 20% or 30% of your
pairs, then you lose
statistical power, and then
you also lose external
validity to begin with.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So there's also the
issue of spillover effect,
which isn't the same.
So one might be that somebody
sneaks into the program who
was supposed to be
in the program.
But the other is, if you do
things in the same community,
which is often the case in the
work that we do, or in a
similar environment, the
mere effect of having
something going on--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And this is why the first
stage is very important.
If you think spillovers will
occur, the moment to think
about them is at the design
stage of the evaluation.
Because then you can decide on
how you're going to randomize
in a way that minimizes
the effect that
spillovers would have.
So there's some statistical
techniques to deal with some
of these problems.
But the best way to do with
these problems is to avoid
them in the first place.
And you avoid them by good
design, where the evaluator
can help, and by a good
monitoring system to make sure
that the evaluation is being
implemented as intended.
Makes sense?
Yes, your name please?
Are you also filming from
this camera here?
OK.
I'm nervous now.
Two cameras.
AUDIENCE: What's on
the [INAUDIBLE]
to avoid [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So I think one important thing
is to have people in the field
who can help monitor, and who
know about the evaluation.
Two is to have a clear
commitment.
This is something that Rachel
said this morning that's
really, really key.
Very clear commitment from
whoever is organizing.
That's very creative.
For whoever is implementing
the program.
So I'll give you an example.
We were evaluating this
program in Jamaica.
And we were telling them,
we need to monitor the
crossovers.
We can't have people who are
not supposed to receive the
program, get into the program.
Yes, yes, yes.
Is it OK if a few do it?
We say, well, only if a few, but
really, this has to be the
exception, and you really have
to monitor this rate, and we
asked them for a report on
this rate, and so on.
This is a government
agency in Jamaica.
And so they were all the
time asking, OK.
How many is too many?
And we were like,
no, no, no, no.
You have to keep that
rate to a minimum.
There's no way you can
have crossovers.
Just keep--
no, but how many, how many?
In one day of weakness,
we said, OK.
If it's more than 10%, this
is completely ruined.
We can't do anything with it.
So end of the evaluation
arrived.
We compute the crossover rate.
9.6%.
So what I want to say here is
that if they didn't want to
comply with our request, they
could have made this rate be
30% or 40% and we would have not
heard anything about it.
I'm not saying 10% is
the right threshold.
It of course depends on the
program and on other things.
But the key thing here is, you
need to have full cooperation
between the people in the field
who are implementing and
the people in the field
who are evaluating.
If you don't have that, then
it's very difficult.
Because people find a way to get
to a program if they hear
that this program is serving,
is doing some good.
So I mean, who's a parent
in this room?
All right.
So now, confess.
If your child, in your school,
there was a randomized trial
on this very promising,
you name it.
After school program.
And your child fell in
the control group.
Would you be at least tempted
to go to the principal and
say, I want my child
in that program?
Tempted?
All right.
I can tell you that other
parents are more than tempted,
and will find a way.
All right.
AUDIENCE: What do you do
with the spillovers?
Do you just exclude them
and put them in
the comparison group?
PROFESSOR: So these are called
crossovers, because they cross
from the control to
the treatment.
The key thing-- this comes at
the analysis stage, and this
you'll do on Friday.
But the key thing is, what
random assignment buys you is
that the two groups are
comparable as a whole.
The whole treatment group with
the whole control group.
You can't then just say,
oh, I don't like this
control group member.
I'm just going to
throw it out.
That completely destroys
the comparability.
You still need to compare the
full two groups, and you do
some statistical adjustments
to deal with the crossover.
But once a treatment,
always a treatment.
Once a control, always
a control.
The random assignment buys you
that two groups are the same.
If you throw away-- suppose
then, 10% of crossovers.
If you throw them away you will
be comparing the whole
treatment group with this 90%
of the control group.
And let's just assume for a
second that that 10% who
crossover are people who are
particularly motivated, and
that's why they switch over.
Well then, the average
motivation of the two groups
were the same at the beginning,
but once you throw
that 10% away, the average
motivation of the treatment
group is going to be higher than
the average motivation of
the control group.
So any difference you find in
outcomes between these two
groups could be due to the
program, but could also be due
to differences in motivation.
You can't throw them away.
There's statistical ways
of dealing with them.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Turns out, I guess I
didn't understand the answer
to the earlier question.
So we're worried about
spillover, and we're going to
deliver books to--
clearly the intervention is that
the kids get books that
they can take home to
study at night.
But I've decided that because
I'm worried about spillover
and because it's more
administratively convenient,
I'm going to deliver
to some schools.
So I'm going to draw the schools
at random, but I'm
looking at the kids,
impact on the kids.
PROFESSOR: That's OK.
AUDIENCE: So even so, I haven't
damaged my ability to
look at the students' effects,
because my unit of
randomization was at
a different level.
PROFESSOR: That's
perfectly fine.
However, the higher the unit
of randomization, the more
trouble you're going to have in
having enough statistical
power to detect effects.
But that's a topic that I want
to leave up to Thursday.
But yes.
I mean, when we say the
schools are treated--
I mean, the schools
are buildings.
They're not being treated
in any way.
Unless you paint them or do
something to them, they're not
being treated--
AUDIENCE: Ours got paint.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So if it's just painting them,
then the schools--
no, but seriously.
When I say treated, who's being
affected by the treatment?
AUDIENCE: Well, I
can't have a--
it's going to hurt my power.
But I can randomize at a
different level than
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You can.
Particularly if you want to
avoid spillovers, that's
exactly what you should
be doing.
All right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: My name is Cesar.
What happened when the
intervention is something
about knowledge?
For example, that some nurse
trained to a treatment group
about wash your hands, and
this knowledge can--
PROFESSOR: Can spillover.
Yeah.
That's exactly right.
So again, you need to think
about the design of the study.
If you really think it's going
to spill over, then you need
to think about randomizing at
a higher level so that the
spillover doesn't occur.
I do have to say one thing.
There's some interventions
where the
spillover is evident.
And you're going to see that
in the deworming case.
I think it's case number 4.
So it's very clear that
this is happening.
There's a human biological
transmission of disease that
makes spillovers very clear.
This is my own bias.
But there are tons of problem
programs out there that have
difficulty affecting
the people that
they're intended to.
So thinking that they're going
to affect other people they
haven't been intending to help,
in some cases at least,
is a stretch.
Having said that, if you think
spillovers will occur, then
you need to think about
that at the design
stage of the study.
yes?
Your name please?
AUDIENCE: Yes, sir.
Raj.
Just getting back to the example
where you were saying
if you took each of us, and
you assigned us to two
different groups, it would
adjust for the unobservable
characteristics.
Would that work out in a
sample size so small?
PROFESSOR: In a sample size
like this, you will have
trouble with statistical--
I want to leave all those
questions of--
you have our superstar, Esther
Duflo, who's going to speak
about statistical power.
But the key thing here is, if
you have a small group, then
what happens is the sampling
error is bigger.
So you may observe differences
between the groups.
You may not declare them to be
statistically significant
because you have very
little power.
So in general, you want
larger sample sizes.
This group is probably small.
But even if you did it with this
group, and I challenge
you to do it--
just take an Excel spreadsheet
and take five
characteristics of you.
And the random assignment,
you're going to see some
differences.
But it's really amazing
how the two
groups will look alike.
And the other thing.
If you're not accounting for
unobservable differences like
some non-experimental
methods do.
The key thing about this is, you
don't need to account for
anything, because the two groups
are balanced across
these two things.
So they have the same average
level of motivation, and so I
don't need to control
statistically for motivation.
Because that cannot be a
confounding factor if the two
groups are the same.
OK?
All right.
So step number six.
If you're going to measure the
impact of a program on an
outcome of interest,
you need to collect
data on that outcome.
And that's called
follow-up data.
And the key thing is, you need
to collect that for both
treatment and control groups.
And it's important that it be
done in identical ways.
So you can't, or it would not
be a good idea, to have
treatment group data come from
one source, say, a survey, and
control group data come from
another source, say,
administrative data, because
data sources are generally not
very compatible to each other.
The seventh step.
Of course, estimate the
program impact.
And if the experiment is
properly done, what you should
be doing is just compare the
outcomes-- the mean outcomes
of the treatment group with
the mean outcomes of the
control groups.
Now, there are versions of the
experiments where they are
more sophisticated, and then you
need to use the multiple
regression framework to
control for things,
particularly if you have
stratified your
sample, and so on.
But in general, the basic idea
is, there are no differences
between these two groups.
Then the simple differences in
outcomes between those groups
should give you the impact
of the program.
There are other reasons you may
want to use the regression
framework, such as statistical
power, that we were talking
about before, but this
is the basic idea.
If the differences between the
two groups is very different
than what you get with the
regression, you should start
thinking about what's
going on.
And then eight.
And I think this is very
important for practitioners.
You should assess whether
the program's impact are
statistically significant, but
also if they're practically
significant.
So if statistically significant
means, we're
confident that this impact
is different from 0 in a
statistical sense.
Having said that, the impact
may still be very small for
any practical purposes.
So it may be that a program
affects some outcome of
interest, but the effect is so
small that you won't decide
that this program was a success
on the basis of that.
So both of those things
are important.
The stars or the asterisks for
statistical significance are
not enough for you to conclude
that a program is successful.
Yes?
Your name pace.
AUDIENCE: Ashu.
Yeah.
I understand we can get the
mean just by seeing the
difference between the
two sample sets.
How do we get a handle on this
trend of standard error and
consequently the statistical
significance?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So again, in the simplest, very,
very simple, you just do
a comparison of two groups, this
is the standard t-test,
there's nothing else to do.
In practice, a lot of this
impact estimation is done
through the regression
framework.
However you're going to do it,
you're going to let your
statistical software calculate
those standard errors.
Of course you need to be careful
about things you learn
on Thursday, such as clustering
and so on.
You need to make sure that those
errors reflect that.
But the basic idea is, you let
your statistical software or
the evaluator calculate
those impacts.
But as a proxy, if the two means
are not different, then
it's going to be hard
to argue that this
program had a big effect.
OK.
So random.
As I said at the beginning,
anyone can tell me, what does
the term "random" mean?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Chosen by chance.
PROFESSOR: Oh, you work for
public opinion polls.
I should have asked you.
All right.
So "chosen by chance."
What does that mean?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
One can say random if there's
no systematic
trend behind the selection.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Systematic trends.
So you don't have someone
saying, you
go here you go there.
So suppose I wanted
to do a random
assignment in this classroom.
And I went here, and I closed
my eyes, and I throw a ball
right here.
I don't see where
I'm throwing.
I just throw it.
Person gets it, falls
into the treatment.
Is that random?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: Why not?
I already turned that
way, right?
AUDIENCE: Maybe you
like the sun.
PROFESSOR: Maybe
I like the sun.
And the people sitting near the
sun may be different from
the people who are not.
Who knows.
The key thing is that when we
say random, particularly in a
simple randomized experiment,
what we mean is that everyone,
every single one of you, has the
same probability of being
selected into the
treatment group.
Or into one of the groups.
Let's say the treatment group.
So the key thing here is that
Iqbal, Brook, Jamie, Jessica,
everyone, Farah, everyone in
this room, if we do a simple
random assignment, you should
have the same probability of
being assigned to the
treatment group.
So it has a precise statistical
definition.
It's not just someone
saying, oh, yeah.
We can't remember
how we did it.
It must have been random.
No.
It has a very, very precise
definition.
Because if you trust someone
telling you, it was random,
and then you trust that word,
and then you start doing your
study, and three years later,
you discover it wasn't random,
you are not going to be very
happy with yourself.
So there are variations
on this.
If you have stratified, it
doesn't mean that everyone
must have the same
probability.
It means everyone
within a strata.
But the basic idea is, before
we do random assignments, we
should know the probability of
everyone being selected.
When I say the same probability
of being selected
into a treatment group,
that probability
doesn't need to be half.
So it could be a third.
It could be two thirds.
From a statistical power
perspective, you
prefer half and half.
But whatever it is, all of
you should have the same
probability of being selected.
Make sense?
OK.
AUDIENCE: In your example of
drawing the ball, is that a
random assignment?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So again, it depends on the
details on how you do it.
But suppose we have balls for,
I don't know, 30 participants
or however many you are, and you
have balls from 1 to 30,
and you mix the bag, and you
really trusted the physics
that by mixing, that all the
balls would have the same
chance of being selected,
and you draw one
ball from the bag--
all the balls had the same
chance of being selected.
All of you had the same chance
of being selected.
AUDIENCE: But the
second person--
so when you draw one,
that's 1 out of 30.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But the second time
you do it, you could have a--
PROFESSOR: So if the sample size
is very, very small, you
worry about sampling with
replacement and without
replacing--
if the population from which
you're drawing is very small,
you may have an issue
with that.
If the population is large, the
difference between 1 in
1000 and 1 in 999, it's going
to be pretty small.
If you do it sequentially
like that.
If you do it in a computer,
you can have a randomizing
device that just generates a
random number, and then you
pick the first half.
OK.
So is random assignment the
same as random sampling?
I see no, yes?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
I need a little bit
more than that.
AUDIENCE: A random assignment,
you would have already
narrowed down to a smaller
sample, and assigned within
that sample.
Random sampling would be taking
a group out of a whole
population.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Very good.
So one way think about this
is you have your target
population, then you have
potential participants.
This may be children you're
targeting to in your
intervention.
And then you have your
evaluation sample.
Here's where the random
sampling could occur.
So--
sorry I forgot your name,
AUDIENCE: I didn't tell you.
PROFESSOR: You didn't tell me.
This is even worse.
Jean.
So what Jean is saying is,
random sampling happened at
this stage.
Or could have happened
in this stage.
What random sampling is buying
you is the ability to
generalize from your
evaluation to
this population here.
And whether this is a population
of policy interests
or not, that's a different
matter.
But that's what random sampling
is buying you.
What random assignment is doing
is once you have the
samples-- so suppose there
are 100,000 potential
participants.
You don't have money to enroll
100,000 people in a program or
in an evaluation.
You pick, out of this 100,000,
5,000 at random, the results
of your study are going to be
generalizable to this 100,000.
Now, within this 5,000, you do
random assignment and you
assign to a treatment group
and to a control group.
Maybe of this 5,000, 2,500 fall
here, 2,500 fall here.
What random assignment buys you
is these two groups are
identical, and so any difference
you observe in
outcomes is due to
the program.
That's internal validity.
That has to do with causal
inference that is about this
5,000 that are here.
So where the 5,000 generalize to
is an external validation.
So they both have the word
"random," but these are two
different concepts.
Again, random assignment relates
to internal validity,
causal inference.
Random sampling refers
to external validity.
yes?
AUDIENCE: My name is Cornelia.
PROFESSOR: I should
know it by now.
AUDIENCE: I haven't
said it yet.
Can you do one and
not the other?
Not really.
Do you have to--?
PROFESSOR: You can, you can.
In fact--
well, sorry.
If it's called a randomized
experiment, this
one has to be there.
This is what defines a
randomized experiment.
there was random assignment.
AUDIENCE: So you can do a
randomized assignment, even if
your sampling is not running.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So what that means is that then
you need to think about
who you generalize to.
All right.
So advantages and limitations
of experiments.
For those of you who are a
little bit more statistically
inclined, the key thing about
random assignment is that not
only on average the two groups
are the same, but the
distribution, the statistical
distribution of the two
groups, is the same.
And this is very powerful for a
lot of the adjustments that
come at a later stage,
particularly when there are
crossovers and similar things.
The idea is that the two groups
not only on average
both unobservable, and
unobservable characteristics
look the same, but the
whole distribution.
So they have the same variance,
they have the same
25th percentile, the same
75th percentile.
And of course, when I say the
same, again, it's in a
statistical sense, subject to
sampling error, which we can
account for.
And so there are--
yes?
AUDIENCE: That doesn't
necessarily mean that they're
both anomolies.
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Anything.
Yeah.
Anything.
But the distribution should
look the same.
OK.
So no systematic differences
between the two groups.
This is deliberately
a repeated slide.
I didn't forget to take it
out of the presentation.
Key advantage, key takeaway
message--
these two groups do not differ
systematically at the outset,
so any difference you observe
should be attributable to the
experiment.
And this is under the big
assumption that the experiment
was properly designed
and conducted.
It's not like any experiment
will reach this.
So other advantages
of experiments.
Relative to results from
non-experimental studies,
they're less subject to
methodological debates.
So a lot more boring
conversations in academic
seminars because there may be
some questions about what
question is being answered,
there may be some questions
about things that happen in
the field that may have
threatened the experiment.
But the basic notion that if it
was done properly, the two
groups should look alike,
it's never debated.
Whereas with non-experimental
methods, that's the whole sort
of central claim of the seminar
and of the presenter.
They're easier to convey.
You can explain to
people, look.
These two groups look alike
at the beginning.
Now there's a difference.
It must have been the program.
And they're more likely to be
convincing to program funders
and/or policymakers.
If they find it more credible,
easier to convey, it's more
likely that they will
take action.
Although in this respect, I
can't emphasize enough what
Rachel said, which is, look.
If you have the right question,
then answering that
question is going to be
important to lead to change.
If you have the wrong question,
even if you did a
nice experiment, it's not going
to help you that much.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I've been to the
conference two months ago.
Some people were arguing that
last first advantage that is
with randomization--
that's random assignment--
how to build two groups that are
identical to each other.
And some people argue that you
will almost never find a
context where you will have
that situation occur.
The way the government programs
operating in most
cases, it is almost impossible
that you find an exact
identical treatment group
and control group.
PROFESSOR: See, the key thing
here is that you don't
need to find it.
It's not like you have a
treatment group and now let's
look in the whole country, where
is the control group?
No.
This method forces the two
groups to be the same.
As long as there are some people
who are going to be
served by the program and some
that are not, if you randomly
assign to these two
groups, the two
groups should be identical.
Not because you were very
smart and looked for the
other group, no.
It's like random assignment is
for those of us who precisely
don't think we can come
up with that other
group on our own.
So there may be issues with
whether you have enough
program applicants to be able
to divide them into two
groups, participants and
non-participants.
But in context where you're not
serving all the two groups--
so if you don't have money to
serve 1,000 people, and 1,000
people applied to your program,
and you only have 400
slots, that's not going to--
this goes to the ethical
issue, which we'll discuss
in a second.
The only thing that changes is
how you select those 400.
But once you've selected
randomly, those two groups
should look identical.
Again, not because you were
incredibly astute at saying,
oh, here's another group.
No.
This this happens through
the flip of a coin.
This is not a researcher a kind
of, oh, can the research
and find a group?
Or the context is development
versus a developed country.
This has to do with
the technique
applied to any setting.
Again, you're going to have
a case where you see a
spreadsheet and you can see,
you can do the random
assignment and see for yourself
that the two groups
will look similar.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Is it necessary that
the size of the two groups
have to be the same?
PROFESSOR: No, it's
not necessary.
And in fact in practice, what
happens is, suppose you had
1,000 applicants and you
had money to serve 600.
Then no matter what the
statistician says-- oh, it
would be nice to have
500 and 500--
you're not going to have 100
people not being served just
because you want to keep
the half-half ratio.
From a statistical perspective
it's ideal to have 50-50
ratio, but only from a
statistical prospective.
If you deviate too much
from that 50-50,
then you get in trouble.
So if you get to--
I don't know.
The rule of thumb
may be different
for different people.
But if you get over 70-30, I
would say probably you're
going to lose a lot
of statistical
power by doing that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but in some
cases, for example, a country
needs to make priority
in aid with about 200
hospitals, for example.
And in my country, there are one
hospital that is the most
important public hospital
in Honduras.
So you can apply this
randomized process.
But if you don't include this
particular hospital, you
cannot include this particular
hospital
because it's too important.
We call that [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[? represented ?]
subject for this type of
problem, who have the
possibility of 1.
Should be in the sample.
I don't know if you understand
my Spanglish.
PROFESSOR: No, no.
I speak Spanish.
We can communicate here.
So the key thing is, Again,
you're trying to create
comparable groups.
If for some reason you need to
serve a hospital because the
president of your country says,
you need to serve this
hospital, that's fine.
One slot.
But that hospital should not
be a part of your study,
because that hospital was
not randomly assigned.
That's all.
As simple as that.
And you may have
a few of those.
I mean, I can tell you, in my
own experience, we're trying
to implement random assignment
in Niger, a program financed
by the Millennium Challenge
Corporation.
A program about building
schools.
We said, we're going to do
a random assignment.
And they say, yes, yes, yes.
Well, the US ambassador visited
two of the villages,
and he promised them they
were getting schools.
Now, you tell me if you want to
be the evaluator and tell
those schools, no, no.
We're going to put you
in the pool of--
no way.
Those two villages are going
to get their schools, but
they're not part of
our evaluation.
AUDIENCE: Is there an
acceptable margin?
PROFESSOR: See, that's again
the Jamaica question.
I won't make that
mistake again.
I won't to tell you.
You're going to see on Thursday
a whole session on
statistical power, and you're
going to get a sense
of where you are.
You don't want to have too many
first, because you lose
sample size, and second
because you lose
representativeness.
I mean, in the case of the
hospital in Honduras, if
that's the hospital where 90% of
things are happening, then
it's a little bit hard to have
that as a hospital that's out
of your study.
So that is an important issue.
All right.
There are limitations
of experiments,
believe it or not.
So the first one is, huge
methodological advantages.
But you still need to worry
about these issues of internal
validity and external
validity.
And what I would say about this
is, on Friday youo're
going to learn a lot about how
to do with these internal
validity issues.
And I'm not going to
go over them now.
But the key thing is, if you
can avoid them from the
beginning in terms of how you
design your program and how
you implement them,
then much better.
External validity issues--
as Rachel said, any impact
evaluation conducted in a
particular setting is going to
have external validity issues.
But experiments are particularly
prone to them
because they're sometimes done
in particularly concentrated
areas where you really want to
find out, does this program
work before expanding
it, so the external
validity issue is there.
As Rachel said, if you can
design an experiment to test
each thing in your theory of
change, that usually helps
with external validity.
And of course, if you
can replicate
evaluation in other settings.
AUDIENCE: So OK, you're going
to have 10 variables with
internal validity, equal
internal validity, but only
three variables with
external validity?
PROFESSOR: When you say three
variables, what do you mean
with variables?
AUDIENCE: The variables that
you are--variables.
The study variables.
I mean, when you're going to
evaluate internal validity,
you're going to have
10 variables or 20.
PROFESSOR: Well, internal
validity, the two groups
should be the same.
And you have pretty strong
internal validity if you can
deal with this problem.
AUDIENCE: When you're going to
the external validity, maybe
not the whole 20 variables will
have external validity.
But maybe your three or four
where you have been made
different experiment in--
PROFESSOR: So it really
depends on the
context of your project.
Again, I think the good
example is deworming.
So deworming, you
take out worms.
Well, in Honduras, if children
who go to school, there are no
worms, and that's not the
reason they don't go to
school, then that program in
Kenya doesn't have much
external validity or
generalizability to Honduras.
So you need to be thinking
about how the effect is
supposed to be happening.
And here there was the anemia
thing, which may work in the
case of Honduras or not.
You need to be seeing,
what is the chain?
And seeing whether that chain is
likely to hold in whatever
other contexts you
want to apply.
There's no magic formula here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but you are
going to control the
theoretical framework with just
three, four variables
because that variable will be
common in different countries?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but you
can have 200 variables.
You can say, it depends
on so many things.
But there's a limit
to how much--
the external validity issue is
an issue that you can always
hide behind it.
You can always say, oh, this
program worked in Kenya.
Who knows whether it would
work somewhere else?
And then if you take that
attitude, then you can't learn
anything from a randomized
experiment, or from any impact
evaluation that's done in
a specific setting.
Because even if you did it in
Kenya, in a particular point
in time, you can always say,
well, it worked in Kenya ten
years ago, but maybe it
won't work today.
So I lean to the middle
ground here.
You sort of think about what
are the critical steps or
stages in which it can work, and
then go implement it, and
maybe evaluate it.
I think my answer here is,
external validity issues are
going to be present for
both experiments and
non-experiments.
There is no magic
formula here.
As long as you evaluate in a
particular setting, you're
still going to be subject to the
question, does it work in
some other setting?
Some of these threats also
affect the validity of
non-experimental studies.
The key thing, though, is that
some of this, in the
non-experimental studies, you
may not even realize that you
have the threat.
Because you've already done
something that allows you to
be blind to the threat.
So other limitations, the
experiment measures the impact
of the offer of the treatment.
So when we implement the
program, and we say, OK, you
are in the treatment group,
you're going to get the
program, as you know from
implementing these programs in
the field, not all of the people
you offer the program
are going to take
up the program.
So what the experiment buys you
is, the whole treatment
group is comparable to the
whole control group.
So the experiment is going to
tell you, this is the impact
for every, on average, for the
whole treatment group.
So some of them may not have
received the program, and some
of them may be diluting
the impact of the
program when you estimate.
But technically, that's the
impact that the experiment is
estimating.
So if you have a program with a
very low take-up rate, then
you need to worry about the
issue that the non-takers are
going to dilute the effect
of the program.
You can then go and calculate,
what is the effect of the
program for those who
participated?
But then you start relying on
non-experimental assumptions.
You've lost a bit the advantage
of the experiment.
So that's something that you
need to think about when you
do an experiment.
There's a limitation
in terms of these
experiments can be costly.
I'll sort of just say two things
about being costly.
I'll say three things
And I did learn that I should
never say "I'll say three
things," and I'll forget what
those three things are.
But I think I'll keep
them in mind.
The first thing--
a lot of the cost of an
experiment is data collection.
So if you are trying to evaluate
the impact of a
program through some other
non-experimental method that
involves data collection, you've
already made the two
costs pretty comparable.
Because again, data collection
is a big cost.
If you had a non-experimental
method where you don't have to
collect data, obviously there's
no question that that
is going to be cheaper.
So it can be costly.
But again, main cost data
collection, which may be the
same for non-experimental
studies that collect data.
But the other thing about the
experiment in terms of cost is
that the same sample size buys
you more statistical power.
And you may see some of
this on Thursday.
So if you have a sample size
of 1,000 people for an
experimental study and a sample
size of 1,000 people
for a non-experimental study,
those data collections' cost
will be identical, but they will
be buying you different
statistical power.
So that's one thing to keep
in mind about the cost of
experiments.
And the last thing is, you need
to factor in, what is the
cost of getting the
wrong answers?
If you really think that
non-experimental methods are
not going to work in your
particular context, then it's
not so useful to invest less
money if you don't think
you're going to get
the same answer.
And again, I don't want to push
the notion that only with
an experiment you'll get
the right answer.
But if you think with a
non-experiment, you won't get
the right answer, then the cost
of the wrong answer, the
risk of a wrong answer.
Ethical issues.
Throw them at me.
AUDIENCE: How do you say no to
people who come to you, saying
I want to put myself
in this program.
I have all the characteristics
you're asking for.
You're offering it
to my neighbor.
How come you're not
offering it to me?
PROFESSOR: OK.
The first thing to think about
here is experiments are
typically done in context where
there's access demand.
Where there are more people who
want to be in your program
than can be served
by your program.
And if that's the case, suppose
you had 1,000 people
who applied to your program,
and you can only serve 400.
The question I ask
you, Cornelia--
and only you--
is how many people are you going
to have to say, sorry, I
can't serve you?
600.
Both in the context of an
experiment and in the context
of a non-experimental study.
The only thing that changes is
how you decide who those 600
people are.
It's the only thing
that changes.
And in fact, in some contexts,
the flip of the coin can seem
more fair then you deciding,
I think this person is more
deserving, or this person--
So in that context, in the
context where you're going to
have to turn away people, then
the ethical issues, in my
mind, are much harder
to justify.
I'm not saying there are no
ethical issues in experiments.
There are some context in which
there are ethical issues.
So if you are completely
convinced that your program
works, then why are you going
to do this whole randomized
experiment?
The only thing I can tell you
is that a lot of people have
been very convinced that some
programs work, and then they
turn out not to work.
But if you are completely
convinced that the program
works, then you shouldn't
be doing it.
And then the other thing is,
if you are testing an
intervention that you think can
harm people, then there
are ethical issues involved.
So I don't think anyone will
be very fond of doing an
experiment to try to find out
whether smoking causes lung
cancer, for example.
Because we don't have
experimental evidence, but the
medical evidence seems
to be pretty
strongly in favor of that.
Maria Teresa?
AUDIENCE: A consequence of that
ethical question, was
hard for me, was people who are
indeed chosen to be in the
program and people
who are not.
You have to come back to these
people who are not and follow
up with them.
And how willing to cooperate
were they to collect more
data, to talk with them.
And you know, working
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] is really
hard, because you take time from
the farmer for two hours
every couple months, and come
back, and standing there.
I mean, while the other guy
received something for these
two hours that are
given to you.
So I think that that is the--
Maybe you need to apply
this more often.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I mean, again, I think there
are things you try to do
to deal with them.
That has to do more with the
implementation of any study in
which you have a comparison
group.
It's not the experiment.
Experiment has a
control group.
With any other study that has
a comparison group where
you're collecting data
faces this issue.
And then there are things
you can do.
It depends on the program.
But certainly sometimes offering
some small incentive
for people in both groups
to fill in the survey is
certainly one thing
that could help.
The other thing that I think
is very important is data
collection.
The average researcher, when
they are asked the question,
do you want to add one more
question to the survey?
The probability of saying yes
is 99% for the average
researcher.
So if you have two hours in the
field, you have to start
thinking, well, how many of this
question do I really need
to be asking?
I mean, that's an issue of
implementation versus--
So I think there ways
to do with this.
But again, it's not unique
to experiment.
It really has to do with how
you implement any study in
which you're going to collect
data on people who are not
receiving any benefit.
Yes?
Ethical issues?
AUDIENCE: Nigel.
I think an answer which--
PROFESSOR: Nigel.
You are from the
Kennedy School.
Very nice to meet you.
AUDIENCE: I'm leaving
next week.
The issue of, even if you had
as much money as you kept to
all give to those 1,000
people, you
can't do them all today.
So the way to do it is say, OK,
we'll do 500 this year and
500 next year.
So you're getting all 1,000
people, but you do your
randomized evaluation
year one.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
And tomorrow there are going to
be two sessions on how to
do roll out design-- there's
a bunch of designs that are
applying the same principle.
AUDIENCE: When you think about
the cost of the study, don't
you think a question you should
deal with way early on
is the size of the impact
that you're looking for?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: If the study is going
to cost me a lot of
money, and there's a significant
probability that
it might have only a small
effect, then that maybe isn't
worth bothering with.
And so you talked about looking
up the size of the
effect and the statistics, and
whether it's statistically
significant.
But that size question,
it seems to me, gets
looked at very late.
And it should be way up front in
the very early days because
of the impact, whether the
program is really of interest,
and worth following.
PROFESSOR: So two
quick reactions.
The first one is what
Rachel said.
Think strategically about
impact evaluations.
You don't want to evaluate every
single thing that's in
your organization or every
single thing under the sun.
You're not going to be able to
do an impact evaluation on all
of those things.
You may do other kinds of
evaluations on hopefully most
of your programs, but an impact
evaluation, you should
be very strategic on
where you do it.
And if you think this is a
program that is not generating
much impact and it's not costing
you that much money,
then you may say, I'm not
going to evaluate it.
The second thing I would say
with regard to that is
thinking about the effect of the
program is something you
need to do at stage one, the
designing of the study.
And this will connect with your
session on sample size
that Esther will speak
about on Thursday.
Because thinking about the
larger that impact is, that
affects your calculations
of sample size.
The paradox in all of this,
despite of what you said, the
paradox in all of this is
that the bigger the
effect of the program--
so if you expect this
program is going
to have a huge effect--
the smaller the sample size
you need, and hence the
smaller the data collection
costs.
So paradoxically, if the
program is extremely
important, the data collection
cost should actually be lower
than a program where you want
to detect effects that are
very small.
Having said that, you want to
evaluate the programs that
make strategic sense for
you to evaluate.
I mean, one thing I think you
should try to avoid, despite
all our enthusiasm with
randomized experiment, you
shouldn't leave this course
thinking, OK.
Where do I see an opportunity
to randomize?
And then forget about what is
it that you're trying to do.
You know, you may find a great
opportunity to randomize, but
if it doesn't answer a question
you care about,
you've just wasted money.
All right, so--
you have a question?
This is very interesting.
AUDIENCE: I want to know, do you
think that in any context,
one can be able to carry out
an impact evaluation?
For any type of program--
PROFESSOR: So my answer
to that is
no, not in any context.
But probably in more contexts
than you think about.
That is my short answer.
AUDIENCE: What about, for
example, infrastructure--?
PROFESSOR: There have been.
It's harder to do.
There have been some studies.
This is actually, I think,
a growing area.
This is an area where people are
trying to do some impact
evaluation.
I mean, if you're building a
road in the middle of the
country, and this is one road
for the whole country--
you can't do it.
But it's OK.
You don't need to do an impact
evaluation for everything you
do, and you don't need to do a
randomized impact evaluation
for everything you do.
What I do hope the message comes
clear is, if you decide
to do an impact evaluation,
then thinking about a
randomized design should
be your first choice.
If you can't do it-- and can't
do it is not just, oh, there's
some issues--
no, no.
Can't do it, really trying,
given all these advantages,
really trying-- if you can't do
it, then you may consider
doing other things.
But this should be your first
option if you decide to do an
impact evaluation.
All right.
Partial equilibrium.
It's a little bit
more technical.
But if you have a program that
only affects some people
differentially.
So suppose you had a program
that was going to train people
on how to have better resumes.
And if you only do it for a few
people, then this program
may have a huge effect.
But if you do it for everyone in
your town, there's going to
be little advantage that's
gained from this.
And so the randomized experiment
estimates a partial
equilibrium effect.
You don't know what would
happen if everyone in a
particular setting got
the treatment.
I think this is important in
some settings, but not enough.
All right.
So I'm not going to go too much
about get out the vote,
because we're already a
minute away from time.
What I want to do is just show
you this table here.
You already discussed it.
So this is what the
case study shows.
This is a situation
where you had four
methods to estimate impacts.
The first four methods
found out that the
program had an effect.
The last method, the randomized
experiment, found
no statistically significant
effect.
I'm not saying that in every
single-- this goes back to
your question.
I'm not saying that
in every single
setting, this will happen.
But this is a good example of a
setting in which if you had
gone with any of these
techniques, you would have
concluded the program had an
effect when it didn't.
And there are other settings
where the reverse may happen.
And so if we were able to
say ex ante, before the
evaluation, this method is going
to be just as good as
the experiment, that's great.
We may be able to save some
money if there's no data
collection involved, and
that would be great.
But I think the bottom
line here is, we
are not always able--
and I think very few people will
tell you, we know when
this method will work.
Because the assumption behind
each of this methods on how
the work is untestable--
you can't statistically
test that assumption.
So you may argue
in favor of it.
You may show evidence
But you can't specifically
test it.
And that's the big advantage
of the experiment.
So let me just close with
what I hope are the
bottom lines from this.
The first thing, what's
underlined there.
If properly designed and
conducted, the social
experiments provide
the most credible
assessment of the program.
But the "if" is a very important
"if." Don't leave
this course thinking,
if it's a randomized
experiment, piece of cake.
Everything will work.
That's not the message that
we want to give you here.
It needs to be properly designed
and conducted.
And for that, you really need
a partnership between the
evaluators and the agencies
implementing it.
They're easy to understand,
much less subject to the
methodological quibbles, and
more likely to convince
policymakers.
These advantages are only
present if they are properly
conducted and implemented, and
you must assess the validity
of experiment in the same
way you assess the
validity of any studies.
Because you're going to have
threats to an experiment
anyway, and on Friday, you're
going to learn how to deal
with some of them.
I hope this was moderately
helpful.
I think I have one of the
toughest sessions to teach,
because you guys, some of you
come completely convinced of
why you want to randomize,
some of you come very
skeptical, and I have to
reach a middle ground.
I hope I did.
If you have one more question,
I'll take it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Have you found that
it's possible to teach
organizations to run their own
randomized trials from start
to finish, even if there are
no economists on staff?
Or does this always sort of
require the intervention or
assistance of outside
modulators?
PROFESSOR: I think, as you
will see throughout this
course, conducting an impact
evaluation, even a randomized
one, does involve some technical
skills and does
involve some practical
experience in doing it.
I'm not saying those cannot be
found in organizations that
are in the field.
But if those skills are not
there, it's going to be very
hard to do it.
Now, you can do a lot
of training on
how to do this things.
But I think it'd be hard to do
it without someone who has at
least done a few of these
and seen some of the
problems that arise.
Because problems will arise--
I mean, no question about it.
You will be asking the
evaluator, how far can we go?
And the evaluator, whoever it
is, whether they're in the
agency or not, needs to be able
to answer that question
in a way that at the end, you
have a credible evaluation.
I'm not saying you need an
expert outside of the
organization.
But I am saying you need
an expert somewhere.
And whether you have it inside
or outside, there's a whole
issue of independence versus
objectivity that
I won't speak to.
AUDIENCE: Consumer
companies do it.
PROFESSOR: Consumer companies?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Procter & Gamble and big
companies like that do
experiments all the time, build
their capability into
the organization, how
they make decisions.
I'm just wondering that if
someone leaving this course
with a few experiments under
their belt could implement
something like this, or whether
you need to go as far
as getting an economics degree
in order to be able to do the
coordinating and evaluation
of this type.
PROFESSOR: So I think to do an
impact evaluation, there are
usually more than one
people involved.
And there are different roles
for different people.
There are some roles who are
having good training in
economics as particularly
useful.
There are other roles where I
would say it's particularly
un-useful to be an economist.
So I really think it depends on
what role a person leaving
this course would like to sort
of play in the evaluation.
And you know, whether leaving
this course, you'll be able to
run your experiments
on your own--
I think would be an extremely
successful
course if that happened.
We have no way to measure the
impact of this program, but if
that were to happen, relative to
what would have happened if
you had not come to this
course, that would be
phenomenal.
I think my sense is unless you
have prior training in this
kind of thing, what this course
will hopefully give you
is the ability to be involved
in an evaluation and to be
pretty good at interacting with
whoever is also involved
in evaluation at asking
the right
question of the evaluator.
This is extremely important.
And being very aware in the
field of what may be
threatening an evaluation.
If you're able to do it on your
own after this, I hate to
say it, but I don't think it's
because this session that you
heard from me today.
All right.
I think I already ate a few
minutes into your time.
It was a pleasure.
I'll be here for a few more
minutes if you want.
I hope you have a wonderful rest
of the course, and see
you somewhere.